[Musique]
bonsoir le début d'une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 bienvenue
si vous nous rejoignez dans cette
édition du lundi 26 26 octobre voici les
titres
focus sur les aidants ces personnes qui
soutiennent au quotidien approche
malades dépendants ou porteurs d'un
handicap une journée nationale dédiée se
dérouler en octobre à rambouillet à une
plateforme d'accompagnement et de répit
leur est proposé et nous recevrons un
plateau awa camara qui vient de publier
le tiroir à bonheur son témoignage
d'aidant familial
toute cette semaine le dossier de la
rédaction est consacrée aux circuits
courts dans les yvelines premier numéro
ce soir sur la racine
cette monnaie locale mise en circulation
en vallée de chevreuse voici deux ans
quel est le premier bilan justement
reportage auprès et des commerçants et
habitants
enfin la dernière défaite du week end
lui aura été fatale à laurent fournier
n'est plus l'entraîneur de l'as poissy
football
l'ex joueur du paris saint germain a été
remercié par le club lanterne rouge de
national 2 qu'il avait rejoint à l'été
2010 9
une semaine après on ne voit presque
plus le parvis du collège du bois
d'aulne à conflans sainte honorine
une semaine après les fleurs bougies
dessins en tout genre continuent
d'affluer
une semaine après les hommages
continuent pour samuel pâtit ce
professeur d'histoire géographie
décapité vendredi 16 octobre par un
terroriste pour avoir montré des
caricatures en classe à ses élèves
samedi parmi les nombreuses personnes
venues se recueillir sur place cette
enseignante francilienne interrogé par
astrid bergère les propos sélectionnés
par eléonore sinoquet je n'ai pas
participé aux marches ou différentes
marches et je trouvais important de
venir là pour lui rendre hommage et ça
que c'est impressionnant parce que je
pensais pas qu'il y avait une ambiance
une telle ambiance quoi on sent le
recueillement ont sans l'incompréhension
et voilà c'est quand même malheureux
d'en arriver là la liberté d'expression
ce au programme donc il n'y a aucun
aucune raison quoi on se doit de
l'enseigné voilà quoi ça fait partie
d'un programme comme le reste dans
l'actualité on a appris cette triste
nouvelle par le biais d'un communiqué de
presse publié sur son compte twitter par
la ville de poissy une fillette de six
ans est décédé samedi à la vérité
vivement blessées après l'effondrement
d'un pan de mur du gymnase patrick k
l'yonne est les faits se sont produits
jeudi dernier vers 12h30 l'incident a eu
lieu au moment où des jeunes participer
à un stage de judo pendant les vacances
est la victime avait été conduite à
l'hôpital necker à paris un autre enfant
du même âge également blessés
hospitalisés ne serait lui plus en
danger selon la municipalité le gymnase
avaient été inspectés en 2017 par une
commission de sécurité une enquête est
ouverte
[Musique]
ils seraient près de 11 millions en
france d'après un dernier baromètre de
la fondation april bba les aidants sont
ces personnes qui accompagnent au
quotidien un proche malade porteur d'un
handicap ou dépendants chaque année une
journée nationale en octobre alors est
consacré pour sensibiliser à ce statut
rang manquent encore de reconnaissance à
rambouillet à une plateforme pour les
aidants d'accompagnement et de répit est
proposé depuis quelques années le
reportage et de justine brasier un
accueil de jour pour les personnes
atteintes de maladies neuro évolutive
c'est ce que propose l'association xxi
mais pas que une plateforme existe pour
accompagner les aidants objectif
prévenir le risque d'épuisement
on peut accepter un aidant à partir du
moment où est la une un conjoint ou un
cd qui a une maladie neuro évolutive ou
à partir du moment où la personne a plus
de 60 ans et est en perte d'autonomie
des ateliers à destination des aidants
sont proposés au programme bien-être
promenade dans la forêt de rambouillet
ou encore ateliers de coaching pour
échanger ce sont des aidants qui se
retrouvent ensemble
animée par un psychologue et l'idée
c'est de parler donc une première séance
de sa situation et en fait les autres
vont aborder des sujets raison mais
pourquoi t'as pas penser à ça ou tiens
tu pourrais peut-être penser à ça parce
que moi je détestais ça marche
valve a donné des pistes en fait pour
que la personne puisse trouver des
solutions sur sa situation
la plateforme d'accompagnement vise à
soutenir les aidants dont la charge
mentale est importante
un besoin qui s'est fait ressentir le
coc vida pas aider les aidants se sont
retrouvés salle 2006 ça a été une vraie
catastrophe pour pour eux et pour les
personnes du coup atteint de maladie
north évolutive donc on voit vraiment
l'importance de la plateforme on voit
vraiment l'importance de l'accueil de
jour aussi pour les aidants l'accueil de
jour de rambouillet est à la recherche
de bénévoles pour renforcer son équipe
en moyenne une cinquantaine de personnes
sollicitées la plateforme
d'accompagnement des aidants mon invité
est justement devenu par les événements
de la vie une aidante familial c'est à
oye camara bonsoir mon sens alors le 20
octobre dernier vous avez publié ce
livre le tiroir à bonheur c'est aux
éditions s active c'est un témoignage de
votre quotidien des dents de familiale
de mère et d'épousé le récit débute en
2009 votre aîné william vient d'avoir un
petit frère son prénom c'est yanis très
vite vous allez vous apercevoir qu il a
de gros problèmes de santé les tpiy
l'éthique polyhandicapés déjà à l'époque
comment avez-vous réagi comme qu'est ce
que vous vous êtes dit à ce moment là je
me suis dit que sa lettre
compliqué et
la première chose qui m'est venue à
l'esprit c'est comment j'allais pouvoir
bâle accompagner dans les démarches au
niveau de l'hôpital être là pour lui et
en même temps est ce que j'allais
pouvoir ou pas reprendre une activité
professionnelle
donc voilà c'est vous a dit à l'époque
et forcément avec la force des choses
vous allez devenir donc une aidante
familiale c'est un nouveau travail au
quotidien on peut dire même un nouveau
combat pour vous mais c'est aussi le
titre du livre que je remonterai la
caméra tiroir à bonheur ça veut dire que
derrière cette épreuve de la vie il ya
aussi
voilà des trésors insoupçonnés des
choses auxquelles on ne s'attendait pas
rebelle surfer tout à fait en fait c'est
vrai que l'arrivée d'un enfant en
situation de handicap et là on est
vraiment dans le polyhandicap vraiment
c'est un chamboulement
on ne sait pas où vous trouver des
solutions c'est pas comment on va
pouvoir lui permettre de faire des
progrès parce qu'il est complètement
dépendant on ne sait pas comment on va
gérer les autorisations au quotidien et
c'est vrai que quand on a ce tableau la
11e' mais ma vie sera plus jamais comme
avant
et est-ce que même je pourrais avoir une
vie sociale
et c'est vrai que très vite les
rencontres des questionnements mais
aussi le soutien de la famille des amis
ont permis à petit s'adapter et trouver
des solutions et dans les solutions que
j'ai trouvé avec maimouna bas une amie
qui est sociologue et c'est mon ami
d'enfance
on s'est posé la question de comment
peut- être créé ma propre activité et de
là est venue la création d'une crèche
micro crèche on en parle justement tout
de suite rappelons que votre parcours
vous êtes né à versailles vous avez 40
ans vous êtes assistante sociale de
formation vous le dites vous allez vous
retrouver à ouvrir une crèche inclusif
qui va accueillir des enfants valides et
des enfants en situation de handicap se
dire que cette épreuve de la vie est là
elle a complètement changé le cours de
votre vie de manière durable
tout à fait en fait le tireur à bonheur
ce titre c'est vraiment pour moi comme
un chemin de résilience le tiroir c'est
comme si ben voilà dans la vie il ya des
choses qui nous permet d'aller de
l'avant et dans ce terroir j ai mis
plein de choses
j'ai mis comme il est à l'heure des
rencontres
parfois ce tiroir issélois nous le
s'alourdit un petit peu mais voilà c'est
comment malgré cette difficulté on peut
quand même rebondir c'est pas forcément
toujours simple mais oui oui en effet le
fait un moment d'être confrontés à cette
situation parce qu'on peut le rappeler
beaucoup de parents d'enfants en
situation de handicap rencontre beaucoup
de problèmes de mode de garde
et si on n'a pas de mode de garde si on
a personne qui nous permet d'avoir des
moments de répit
on peut pas continuer une vie sociale en
tant que tel donc cette crèche était une
réponse
en tant que parent d'enfant ça sont des
handicaps et très vite une réponse qui
s'est ouvert à d'autres parents dans
cette situation après on a voulu cette
crèche mixte ce qui veut dire qu'on
accueille des enfants porteurs de
handicap mais aussi les enfants valides
et aussi des enfants qui ont des parents
dans un caisson dans un parcours
d'insertion sociale et professionnelle
je vous dis de rebondir c'est justement
si rebondir avec d'autre part parce
qu'en 2016 vous fonder une association
qui s'appelle second souffle avec
d'autres parents qui est basée à la
queue-lez-yvelines pour soutenir
justement les accompagner les aidants
familiaux et et leurs proches on le
voyait aussi dans le pré c'est un
reportage le moc lice c'est
l'accompagnement vous dit vous vous êtes
retrouvé seul aux 6 au début de cette
situation il faut être accompagné être
tout à fait en fait ce qui est un peu
spécifique aux situations des parents
d'enfants en situation de handicap c'est
la diversité des handicapés des maladies
qui vont du trouble du comportement aux
troubles psychiques au handicap moteur
ou handicap sensoriel et plus encore au
polyhandicap mais également au fait que
ces longs l'accompagnement il est long
dans le temps on peut devenir aidant
d'un enfant a à peine 25 ans et cet
enfant va l'accompagner jusqu'à la fin
de notre vie et de par ailleurs parfois
même un autre nos parents qui sont aussi
malades on peut se retrouver dans la
doubler dans ce très rapidement et c'est
vrai que
se dire qu'on est dans ce n'est pas
forcément une évidence mais avant tout
par an beaucoup ne savent pas quelles
sont exactement
je crois que il ya plus de 50 % de
personnes qui ne savent pas qu'ils sont
évidents et c'est vrai que le fait
finalement de se reconnaître un moment
aidant c'est aussi reconnaître que oui
il ya des conséquences sur la santé sur
la conciliation de la vie sociale et
professionnelle sur la fratrie sûr
voilà le quotidien sur la situation
professionnelle et ce qu'on dit souvent
je pense à une présidente d'association
de l'association qui me laissait amie
sandra qui dit souvent que en tant
qu'aidant on veut avoir le choix souvent
c'est vrai que on va avoir le choix de
pouvoir mettre nos enfants en
établissement ou pas donc là on veut
avoir le choix de reprendre une activité
professionnelle si on en a envie
et là c'est vrai que parfois on est un
peu oublié où nos enfants sont un peu
oubliés m'a parfois certains d'entre
nous le sentiment d'être un peu
invisible et c'est pour ça que c'est
important de dire qu'on est là 11
millions c'est une personne sur six on
est tous des aidants potentiel donc
c'est important vraiment je pense de
sensibiliser d'accompagner et de
soutenir et d'écouter les aidants et le
message du coût de votre livre pourquoi
avoir eu envie de coucher votre histoire
sur le papier c'est de dire vous n'êtes
pas seuls ne baissait pas les bras
c'est vraiment ça c'est ça et puis c'est
vrai que à la naissance de mon fils j'ai
cherché des livres jorma il ya des
témoignages n'y a pas de souci mais
c'est vrai qu'un jour je suis entré dans
une librairie et j'ai demandé à savoir
s'ils avaient des témoignages de parents
et on mate d'ibm a annoncé plus des
blogs
il ya là aidants familiaux pour les nuls
qui est une collection et qui est très
bien d'ailleurs
et là je me suis dit ouais c'est vrai
qu'à l'époque j'aurais voulu avoir un
livre qui me permettent de ne sait pas
gagner du temps mais de dire des choses
les fois qu'on ne peut pas dire que oui
des fois c'est fatigant que oui des fois
on a envie de passer le relais mais
également que oui un avenir est possible
et que l'on peut voir ouvrir des tiroirs
à bonheur et avoir une vie sociale
pleine et sereine et se livre donc le
tiroir à bonheur c'est aux éditions s
active on a vu d'ailleurs quelques
images et une pièce de théâtre qui a été
menée par votre association qui a été
fait autour de cette thématique qui sera
reproposer vous ne disiez tout à l'heure
en tout cas le tireur abonnés un jeu 10è
édition s activent au tarif de 14 euros
merci d'avoir été là avec nous en
plateau merci à l'auteur de ce livre le
tiroir à bonheur
[Musique]
l actualité c'est toujours aussi
l'épidémie de kovy 19 et la deuxième
vague qui s'intensifie dans le
département avec ces derniers chiffres
taux d'incidence est taux de positivité
toujours en haut ce sont les chiffres
hospitalier qui inquiète surtout 65,5 %
des lits de réanimation sont désormais
occupés en ile de france les
établissements yvelines enregistré 102
hospitalisations supplémentaires en une
semaine liée au corona virus 52 patients
étaient hier toujours en réanimation
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
618 personnes sont mortes dans les
hôpitaux du département
vous le savez face à ce constat le
gouvernement on pourrait dès cette
semaine durcir la mesure du couvre-feu
voir prendre de nouvelles décisions ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'à partir de
mercredi le trafic des transports dans
la région sera considérablement réduit
après 21h annonce de l'autorité
organisatrice ile-de-france mobilité en
moyenne après 21h un train sur deux
circulera sur le réseau et des rer et
transilien un bus sur deux également
trois trains sur quatre continueront de
rouler sur la ligne tht et 6 à viroflay
vélizy une mesure pour s'adapter à la
baisse de fréquentation due au
couvre-feu selon des dernières données
elle serait de 13% après 21h et je suis
très à presque 0 % après 23h transport
toujours et cette distance 1,6 km c'est
ce que va parcourir prochainement une
navette autonome en test à saint quentin
en yvelines dès 2021 l'itinéraire
partira de la gare située à montigny le
bretonneux jusqu'à la zone d'activités
du pas du lac où se situe plusieurs
entreprises ce nouveau moyen de
déplacement circulera toutes les 6 à 8
minutes en heure de pointe de 7h30 à 20h
l expérimentation mise en place par
ile-de-france mobilité l'agglomération
démarrera au printemps prochain et ce
pour deux ans reconductible interview
collectées par eléonore sinoquet c'est
une navette effectivement acquis qui
sera totalement autonome et ce qui sera
intéressant pour nous c'est de voir
comment cette nouvelle technologie et
comment ce nouveau type de mobilité
s'articule avec les autres mobilité sur
l'espace public sur la voie publique
voir comment elle se comporte
on aura nos une doctorante qui suivra de
près 7
cette expérimentation notamment pour
avoir des remontées en termes de données
d'algorithmes toujours dans cette idée
de pouvoir progresser sur cette
technologie
et voir si ça peut être une telle une
technologie père est né viable pour un
type de mobilité dans les années à venir
et pendant la durée de l'expérimentation
ses trajets en navette autonomes seront
gratuits environnement les effets du
dérèglement climatique qui s'observe
aussi dans les yvelines l'été dernier le
département a connu un nouvel épisode de
canicule et de sécheresse ces
conséquences vont se ressentir à long
terme dans les forêts et les
précipitations récentes n'auront pas
d'effet résorbant le reportage de marie
pas notera et d'astrid bergère à
versailles l'office national des forêts
observe de nombreux changements sur les
arbres depuis cinq ans en cause la
sécheresse
ce manque d'eau de façon récurrente plus
la canicule on a des épisodes
caniculaires de plus en plus fréquent en
ile-de-france fait que les arbres n'ont
pas accès à la ressource d'eau et en
plus de ça on un deuxième système d'
alerte
c'est à dire qu'ils vont arrêter de
transférer pour éviter de perdre de
l'eau par leurs feuilles
conséquence directe la chute des
feuilles sur le sommet des arbres et
sans feuilles lapointe ne peut pas
croître et fabriquer sa sève tout
doucement l'art va mourir donc si ça se
répète régulièrement un sujet sain un
arbois s'en va pouvoir accepter une
année voilà c'est une année de disette
entre guillemets mais si ça se reproduit
chaque année mais ne va pas pouvoir
grandir il va pas pouvoir s'alimenter et
donc la phase terminale c'est
malheureusement la mort du sujet la
situation inquiète les forestiers il
observe les arbres et tente de chiffrer
le pourcentage dimpre dépérissants et
leur évolution
donc seules les feuilles basses on voit
ici là sont ouvertes sont encore verte
pour certaines ont commencé voilà
commencé à dépérir ça commence tout
doucement et puis ensuite la feuille est
complètement marre ont ensuite celle
ramos donc quand on monte en haut on se
rend compte qu'on a de moins en moins de
feuilles et puis des rameaux
complètement sec c'est à dire que cet
individu là et condamné est dans sa
phase descendante et l'année prochaine y
aura plus du tout va il sera
complètement et les dernières pluies ne
suffisent pas parce qu'elle arrive au
début du repos végétatif
il faudrait qu'il pleuve au printemps
pour que la situation s'améliore
comme à chaque fin de mois le dossier de
la rédaction toute cette semaine nous
nous intéressons aux circuits courts
dans les yvelines cela fait maintenant
deux ans que la racine existe c'est une
monnaie locale complémentaire et
citoyenne utilisés notamment
en vallée de chevreuse le premier bilan
est dressé avec marie pas neutre à et
célia gars tsongo en octobre la racine
fête ses deux ans d'existence
l'association compte près de 500
adhérents
pour ce faire ils payent 8 euros par an
de cotisation pour rappel un euro est
égale à une racine et la monnaie permet
de favoriser une économie circulaire et
locales
le bilan reste mitigé on rencontre deux
obstacles le premier finalement c'est
que les particuliers sont très peu
nombreux à rentrer dans le jeu du coup
on a les professionnels qui dit oui mais
moi personne demande d'utiliser la
monnaie locale je vois pas pourquoi je
la prendrai le deuxième point c'est
finalement les pouvoirs publics
je pense par exemple aux communes aux
collectivités territoriales qui devrait
pouvoir adhérer aux monnaies locales
cela n'a pas découragé sylvie boes
d'adhérer fidèle à l'association dès sa
création elle cotise à hauteur de 45
euros par an et cinq de ses clients
règlent enracine chaque mois la gérante
voit toujours l'intérêt d'utiliser la
monnaie notamment pour payer ses
fournisseurs
le fait de payer en euros en fin de
compte après cet argent va aller à la
banque va être utilisé dix ans et après
donc cet argent à la banque on ne sait
pas où elle va à qui elle va servir à
peut-être à l'international mondialement
etc
non c'est pas à quelle fin alors que là
si je le paye enracine obligatoirement
je sais qu'il va le réutiliser
obligatoirement au local et que ça va la
faire rêver gérer une dynamique pour
l'avenir elles restent intéressés par
l'utilisation de cette monnaie tant que
la racine existera le sport et du
football laurent fournier n'est plus
l'entraîneur de l'ess poissy l'ancien
joueur du paris saint germain a été
remercié ce dimanche soir au lendemain
d'une nouvelle défaite la septième de la
saison les yvelinois sont bons derniers
de nationale 2 le coach avait rejoint le
banc pisciacais à l'été 2010 9 pour le
moment le nom du successeur n'est pas
connu la fois ci a salué laurent
fournier sur twitter pour son
investissement et lui a souhaité pleine
réussite dans ses futurs projets une fin
de collaboration survenue donc après une
énième déconvenue de l'équipe yvelinois
c'était un samedi face aux essonniens de
sainte geneviève des bois
le résumé de la rencontre avec astrid
bergère et michael et demi d'euros
c'était le match à ne pas perdre pour
l'as poissy derniers du classement les
yvelines
recevez sainte geneviève pour un derby
francilien malmenés en première période
les joueurs de laurent fournier encaisse
un but à zéro ce sera le score à la
pause
voilà première mi temps pas grand chose
si ce n'est que pas beaucoup d'occasions
eux sans créer une ont fait une erreur
sur le côté un centre on est inattentif
on prend ce but en deuxième période fois
ci revient sur le terrain avec plus de
combativité les pisciacais se procure
les occasions et arrive à obtenir un
penalty sur cette main fabien raddas
marque fois ci revient au score un but
partout à la 69e minute de jeu mais
sainte geneviève marque sur l'une de ses
seules occasions de la seconde période
de 2 à 1 ce sera le score final
sentiment d'injustice parce que parce
qu'on a plus d'eau casey que je pense
que sur la deuxième mi-temps au mérite
on mérite au moins le point du match nul
ce résultat n'arrange pas poissy le club
s'enfonce au classement l'épicé qui sont
toujours bons derniers de la poule avec
déjà sept défaites
c'est rageant faut serrer les dents je
pense que même si on perd aujourd'hui
c'est de bon augure dans le sens où on
fait une prestation correcte il ya des
matches où on fait des prestations de
vraiment lamentable là aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on peut
reprocher à tous les acteurs de l'équipe
de poids si je sais pas grand chose on
va pas renoncer après
savez le football ça va vite c'est moi
je suis là pour entraîner pour faire
progresser un groupe c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué mais voilà on s'accroche
voici tentera de se relancer lors de la
prochaine journée contre l'équipe
réserve de corps le 7 novembre à
domicile
laurent fournier ne sera pas sur le banc
l'entraîneur a été démis de ses
fonctions le lendemain de cette défaite
contre sainte geneviève
avant de vous laisser cette information
tv 78 la dernière étape du tour de
france 2000 21 partirait de chatou
l'annoncé officielle du parcours est
prévue ce jeudi les coureurs devraient
s'élancer de cette commune pour aller
jusqu'aux champs-elysées le dimanche 18
juillet 2021 chatou qui avait accueilli
en 2018 déjà le départ du paris nice
donné depuis l'île des impressionnistes
pour rappel la dernière étape du tour de
france partira des yvelines jusqu'en
2023 et dans un instant justement ne
manquez pas le cetud sport pour faire le
tour de l'actualité sportive dans le
département voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]